and it was one of those pivotal moments
where I sat there and I said I love you
very much you brought me into this
country you've educated me I'm grateful
but you can't tell me who I'm gonna be I
thought about suicide a few times
because I didn't really see the brighter
side of things who was really angry at
me and said you don't have all the
answers you're not always right and some
of the stuff you do is wrong now every
business that I've invested in hasn't
been a success I've had failures much
like most people
hello believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
on your journey today we're gonna learn
from entrepreneur investor and TV
personality Marcus lemonis and my take
on his top ten rules for success vol 2
rule number 2 is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best also as you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired by it as
well and if you leave it within the
first couple hours of this video going
live you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes
I was born in Beirut Lebanon I lived in
an orphanage and I was adopted by a
American Lebanese family they brought me
to Miami Florida wonderful parents I'm
an only child who may have picked up on
that and I had a really rough childhood
I mean I was very overweight both my
parents work like a lot of parents do it
to two-income household spent a lot of
time eating snacks that I should have
been eating not exercising properly and
became very introspective and depressed
I thought about suicide a few times
because I didn't really see the brighter
side of things developed a terrible
eating disorder I developed bulimia
where I would eat and throw up because I
was trying to be somebody that I wasn't
and as I got older I kept searching for
a reason to exist a purpose and what
ended up happening for me is that I
realized that I was pretty good at
numbers and I was good with human
interaction and I was able to put those
two things together and and realize that
maybe business was the place that the
playing field was unleveled what
happened even further is that I chose
small business which is my platform sort
of what I do
I chose small business because I was
gonna be matched up with somebody that
was like me people say well what do you
mean like you most small business owners
are underdogs and I always felt that I
was an underdog I didn't really have all
the assets in there and me and the you
know the pointers so I matched up with
small business because I said I didn't
realize some success and now I'm gonna
fight for you my family had a car
dealership
Abraham Chevrolet in anymore hands my
grandfather you're kidding no I used to
do commercial I know you did I didn't
want to tell anybody that before I came
in here but I've seen a lot of them I
remember having a conversation with my
grandfather about his wealth and most
people don't know this about him but
he's he was a wonderful man but he was a
very confident man and when I decided to
run for office I was 21 years old I came
back from college and I decided to run
for the State House in Florida 21 and my
family's big Republicans and I
registered as a Democrat and the
newspaper came out one morning Miami
Herald came out of my mother
call me and she said we have a problem
she said what's that he said your
grandfather would like to see you at the
office
okay I drove down there seven o'clock in
the morning and as you know he worked
every day and he said I just want some
good news for you you're fired and I
said wait a minute
hi this is where I work he said give me
your demo keys here's your last paycheck
good luck to you and I said well why am
i fired he said number one you're
running as a Democrat and you know that
we're big Republicans and number two I
told you that you need to clear stuff
with me before you just go off and doing
your own thing and it was one of those
pivotal moments where I sat there and I
said I love you very much you brought me
into this country you've educated me I'm
grateful but you can't tell me who I'm
gonna be and I said you have a lot of
money but I promise you one day I'll
have more and we didn't talk for about
10 years and he died when he was 103
years old and I saw him about four
months before he died and he said to me
you know what I was harder on you than
anybody else because I knew that I
brought you to this country for a reason
and I knew that you were gonna do great
things
what would your definition of literally
the word strategy be what does Stratton
what what does that word and the moment
decision for me I'm not a planner for me
I'm not a planner and you know
ultimately I know where I want to get to
in a particular business but I think the
strategy for me is something that is
very in the moment in the circumstance
in my bigger businesses like my business
Camping World there's clearly a strategy
it's very different because there's four
billion dollars of Revenue 8,000 people
big leases there's an investor
expectation in the small businesses it's
trying to survive and trying to stand
out in a crowd so the strategy is very
different for me in my small business
world it is in the moment without a plan
at some point in the future when the
business matures and it becomes truly
viable and scalable then a normal
process would be put in place so in my
camping oral business my strategy is all
about where do we want to get you in one
year three year five year what are the
people that I need to help execute that
and what's their role gonna be in that
process in every instance though plus or
minus I always tell them that I reserve
the right to change the plan at any
moment and that has always been my
strategy change constantly in the early
2000s I was in the automobile business I
was working for a fantastic company
called Auto Nation and Lee Iacocca
family friend of mine gave me some
really good advice he said if you want
to be really successful in business you
have to be a big fish
well I think you'll be successful in the
car business it's a very big pond so he
recommended that I got in to the RV
business because he felt like it was
fragmented and it was ripe for
consolidation he was right I may not be
the biggest fish but I'm not the
smallest guppy I think the best way to
think about entering into the business
world and being a big fish in a small
pond is to really think about your local
trade area first I call it the basic
trade area that's the environment that
you live in or you want to do business
in and there's a given radius to it four
miles five miles if you want to get into
a business where you're going to be a
big fish then you should really study
that environment you should understand
what type of businesses exist there and
which ones don't and then once you make
the list of the ones that don't do a
little research and really understand is
that a business that I could learn do I
understand something about it and most
importantly am i passionate about it if
you're not passionate about it you don't
understand it I don't care how big a
fish you think you're gonna be you're
gonna get fried I think what people
don't realize is that when you own a
business the personal sacrifice that you
have to make you're not home as much I
don't have kids I'm not married you just
don't have the time to do it all and I
know you can relate to it that when
you're doing your craft oh I lost a lot
of marriages you lose marriages or came
first do you lose friends and I've had
people say to me I can't be in a
relationship with you you don't have
your priorities right and I said I do
have my priorities right you just don't
agree with them my advice to people is
no matter who you are or where you come
from to really be yourself but if you
don't have humility in this very
arrogant society that we're living in
right now you won't succeed if you are
mean like people are mean out there
right now you won't succeed ultimately
you may succeed in the short term and
you may succeed for a few years even for
years but you will not succeed forever
you don't have to be in a small piece of
business advice anyone's ever given you
it was probably given to me by another
by a small business owner that I was
investing in who was really angry at me
and said you don't have all the answers
you're not always right and some of the
stuff you do is wrong and realizing that
that was actually true that was advice
essentially what that person was telling
me was stop acting like you know
everything it was more impactful for me
coming from somebody who was struggling
then it was from somebody who was
successful
oddly enough like I'm not a big like who
is your mentor I had my mom I don't
really have a lot of business mentors I
don't read business books I am NOT
I don't read any I just I feel like I I
can eat I can go live a book write I can
go meet different people I tend to take
advice from people who I don't know why
I do this I tend to take advice from
people who are a little less obvious and
a little less proud to give me advice
there's certain people I hadn't met
people in the history of my life that
are their older son I'm gonna give you
some advice that doesn't work as well
with me as somebody who's really
struggling saying I have to be honest
with you I want to give us that advice I
don't have any
like yeah persons right they don't
did it change the way I thought how did
you get the idea of the [ __ ] I went
through a really bad crisis in 2008 and
nine with my business during the
downturn the RV the RV business is like
taking the housing market and the car
business and bushing them together and
there were days where I really thought I
was going to lose everything and I
remember laying off a lot of people and
coming out of that recession thinking to
myself that the country had really
gotten into a really dark place and I
had suffered from a lot of problems as a
child whether his eating disorders are
being sexually abused where I felt like
I was always the underdog and I don't
know what happened but I felt very
blessed coming out of that downturn that
I had to do something different and so I
met with CNBC and I talked to them about
the fact that they were very strong on
big business and very strong on telling
people how bad the market was and
fortune 500 companies and nobody was
kind of fighting for this untold story
and I really felt like my big mouth and
my checkbook you can kind of solve some
of those problems I don't really feel
like I'm gonna be able to solve all of
them but you know I've I've done 45
episodes and spent over thirty million
dollars of my own money trying to solve
those problems and I think for me what's
changed I said I'm meeting kids that are
7 8 9 10 years old that are now telling
me that they think it's cool to own a
business
when kids before would tell you it's
cool to be a professional football
player every business that I've invested
in hasn't been a success I've had
failures much like most people whether
it was running for office as a state
legislator when I was 21 and losing or
watching certain businesses that I
invest in misjudge people or misjudged
process or misjudged the product and
I've also lost but at the end of the day
I keep a scorecard and the scorecard
isn't about just dollars and cents it's
how much do I enjoy investing in the
business and is this a business that I'm
really proud to put my name on that to
me is the true testament some businesses
have great returns and some have average
returns sometimes the ones receive
average
are the ones that are most enjoyable
I'll give you a real quick story I went
and did a speaking engagement in Chicago
about two years ago somebody in the
audience participated with me they went
home they applied to the show they ended
up being the premiere episode of the
next season
I forgot how I met them I totally forgot
about it and now they're the biggest
success story on the history of the show
what would be the moral of that story
for you all the story is take a chance
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because black asked me
to if there's someone you like me to
profile in their future top ten please
check out the link down in the
description below and you can cast your
vote on who we should do next I also
want to give a quick shout out to Josh
Vern from flock you thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and creating that review on
your website and for being a guest on my
channel as well before I really
appreciate the support and I'm so glad
that you guys enjoyed the read thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we can't you need to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
[Music]
when I was younger and I first started
making money it was fun to sort of buy
things I had a Bentley and I thought I
was a badass and it was sort of I think
the best part of sort of having success
is being able to help other people and
it sounds corny and I don't mean give
money away yeah I mean sort of take
chances on people and so you I'm part of
the reason that I do this show is to
sort of give people hope that you can
invest in other people and give them a
shot but it's it's probably more than
that than anything else you seem like an
amazing guy to work for I think I guess
what I could be [ __ ] to but but I'm
very I'm be honest I mean I'm I just am
very passionate about what I do what's
your biggest business criticism of your
friend
we always had disagreements about this
he's always like thinking ahead about
like he's always working on his next
renovation his next service and I'm like
more like what you're saying but what
about this so I think he's renovated too
strong me to hold that 104 yeah just to
make sure you don't spend it god I think
he's renovated the store a bunch of
times he's oh he's putting up tents in
the backyard
astroturf you know it's always like he's
trying he's so passionate about the
what's best for the dog and and I'm like
oh slow down a little bit okay yeah I
mean my idea right people buy services
based on cosmetic too because before
there we had gravels on the floor yeah
you know I always used to complain hey
you know the graph was too hot for my
dogs feed all right there is always an
issue so I try to invest in ways to
cosmetic and make the places but I want
you to have a plan and I want you to say
over the next three years here are the
things that I want to do and here's what
it's gonna cost me and I'm gonna stick
to the plan because what I hear from him
is you're kind of just doing something
different and changing it all the time I
mean I its reinvest in no but I hear we
know that's a good word yeah the best
things a good way you're in your
apartment because you live there and you
don't like the way it looks so every
once in a while you're gonna repaint the
place no no it's not it's it's not even
that okay
truly about the store like so the
downstairs the wall used to be here and
now it's here now it's here
used to be you know I mean like honestly
if you ask how many time he's renovated
in the past 18 months it's probably
three different though it's different
unique improvements 2008-2009 maybe even
part of 2010 the world was a very dark
place it's dug for everybody I'm not
sure that the lights necessarily come
back on yet but for me it was maybe the
darkest point in my life at that moment
while the world was crumbling I thought
my business was gonna crumble as well
and the RV business is kind of
interesting it's like taking the housing
market which was crumbling and the auto
business which is crumbling and crashing
them together and making an RV so as you
can imagine it was not a recipe for
success that point I had to layoff over
1,500 people not people that were bad
employees or non performers it was truly
in survival mode when you really talk
about humility and maybe even in the
early 2000s I lost some of it it truly
brought me back down to earth so as I go
into these businesses and I meet owners
who tell me that it's tough to make the
hard decisions or they're unwilling to
make the hard decisions it's very easy
for me to become forceful about the
importance of surviving small business
in America could be the single hardest
thing to execute what I feel good about
is that all these big businesses that
have this wild success started as a
small business every business in America
that's successful today started as an
idea in someone's garage
you